foreign
go for it Kelly
my friends let their kids drink alcohol
in a quote unquote controlled setting
what are your thoughts on this
not smart
and by friends you mean you I know that
you do this
no I'm just kidding um okay uh let me
let me think through this out loud
um number one like I had this I
experienced this as a kid so not as a
kid but as a
late teenager and on into college so
um I get this I get it I've been there a
couple of things let's do the pragmatic
stuff first
when it comes to teenagers there's no
such thing as a controlled setting as
much as you think there is there just is
not
um
teenagers are brilliant at navigating
boundaries they're incredible at it
um and so the idea that you're going to
create some kind of bubble that they can
do dumb stuff in or break the law in
um make wise choices in is nonsense it's
just dumb you're wrong you're incorrect
so the number two man
when I was a kid there was no cameras
anywhere ever
there was no video I mean it just wasn't
the liability a parent takes on nowadays
is madness
I can't fathom a an adult doing that in
in this day and age with so many cameras
so many recordings so much all of it
right
um in such a increasingly litigious
Society one thing goes wrong one kid
gets sick one kid gets in a wreck one
kid starts feeling depressed one kid
fill in the blank man since crazy text
or sext somebody or asks for it and
receives it and
I I don't know why anyone would put
themselves in that position
and let's take the broader view with
kids
when I look at the data
this is just the data right I like a
beer as much as the next guy I like a
great bourbon whiskey just as much as
the next guy
I'm just looking at the science part
alcohol is destroying people from the
inside out
it's destroying them at the micro level
where one or two drinks a night is
slowly eroding sleep which is slowly
eroding mental health which is slowly
eroding physical health which is slowly
eroding work performance and
relationship performance and tracks all
the way to dementia and Beyond
and alcohol on the macro level on the
deaths of Despair when we step back and
look at alcohol and then its sister
um opioids
why in the world
why in the world would you lean over to
a kid a child
and say I'll introduce you to something
that the data tells me might be a part
of killing you in the future why don't
you do that
I don't I I just I'm not gonna do that
um
parents are desperately I mean children
are in desperate need of parents who
aren't acting like their friends
children are desperate need of adults
acting like adults and being parents and
saying no as a society we've all voted
you gotta be 21. sorry gotta be 21.
um and that's not even like the motion
picture association association of
America like a group of people in some
shadowy room deciding what the rating of
a movie is as an adult cool you get to
do you get to figure that out
but we all voted as a society
I I just want to lean on that so that's
my thoughts on that Kelly what do you
think
I mean I I remember having a couple of
parents of friends of mine when I was in
high school that would let us do that
and
um but now as a parent no way
no chance if like you said every camera
every phone but I've also seen the
effects of alcohol on people in my life
and there's no chance that I would
introduce my child to that yeah or
somebody else's child without especially
without their knowledge
um because I remember growing up and we
had a particular friend whose parents
would let us drink over there they were
calling our parents they never called
and said is this okay no but they were
the cool Mom right you know and now I
have no desire to be the cool Mom no
thank you no we need a generation of
parents who are don't want to be the
cool parents yeah we'll be friends but I
said I said well we're not friends no
we're not we'll be friends later you're
25 yeah it will be friends so I can't
imagine
um yeah introducing that and I feel like
I'm going to talk out of both sides of
my mouth now when I'm when I'm talking
about Downstream effects of alcohol
I would I would take my kid out and buy
in their their their supposed first
drink when they're 21. I do that right
um it's within the like I wouldn't have
problem with that
but to take a child in and say hey I
don't know I just it just feels stupid
and it's it's illegal yeah yeah yeah
period yeah on huge levels because like
you said you just don't know what
they're going to go out and do and
you're right that saying controlled
setting with a teenager
I think back to the quote-unquote
controlled settings we had yeah that was
before we had the world in our hands in
a box where we could take a picture and
tell somebody and then all of a sudden
it's before you know it it's all around
school it's just no way it's just stupid
yeah good for you
all right
um who is the person besides your
parents that you look up to or seek
advice from
um gosh
um I would categorize that in experts
and mentors and friends and so
um
experts on like I remember when covet
came out I I didn't know anything about
viruses I was super privileged I had
friends who worked in that world that
were research biologists who studied
stuff so when it came to like should I
get the vaccine or not I
them because they knew I didn't uh when
it comes to uh
like Landscaping things you know what
I'm good at when it comes to Landscaping
mowing that's it and dude I can work an
edger a weed eater like like I'm
incredible
but I call Rachel Freitas to come over
and lick look at my yard and she's a
friend and she's also like a renowned
expert in this so
um I ask experts for their ideas on
things I asked Dave Ramsey for personal
money uh tips right and I know most of
many people millions of people in
America would love that and
haha but I I mean I just asked him for
it um I asked Kelly for like at tattoo
aftercare information because she's an
expert she's got a thousand
um and then I got friends that I just
love and have done life with it uh I
trust and they trust me and so when I've
got a hard decision to make or a
conversation or making sure I'm seeing
something right I love asking them for
that kind of stuff
um and then mentors you know
um
men and women who have been with me for
a long long time and that I've looked up
to for a long time that I reach out to
for help and support like Darby
Dickerson or like Jonah Thompson or like
uh Randall demand oh I mean I could just
go on and on and on but uh men and women
who have really been important to me in
my life trajectory so um yeah I guess
experts mentors and Friends
the sun right yeah that's good not
notice the internets not the internets
no not never
the only time it's good to go to the
internets is if you're looking for stuff
that I'm saying and it's great you
should all run to the internets and hit
subscribe all right go for it all right
best way to stay connected to our teens
um the the research would say
be very firm hold kids strongly
accountable and be very kind
it's the combination of both of those
things and there's a four quadrants
um but ultimately it's
be a parent and don't be an ass both of
those things together
um we often like
I've got a whole new accountable I'm
gonna wear them out what an idiot why
would you do that and I want to be cool
I want to be kind so I'm not going to
hold them accountable well that's dumb
too you can do both
you can with love in your heart say Hey
We're not gonna do that
I as your parent can't allow that I as
your parent I've got to make the call to
this teacher to this whatever I've got
to call this mechanic who I think's
ripping you off well I'm gonna I want to
be a I know I'm your parent so it's uh
firm and accountable and kind the thing
that I've been wrestling with lately
um
that I think all parents could really
really work on myself I'm and I put
myself number one at this top of this
list
what if we focused on being likable with
our kids if we focused on
um not again I think I've talked about
this a little bit but not turning every
every conversation into a teaching
moment and not turning every good thing
or failure thing into a moment where I
can imprint on
my oldest son uh he's almost 13 he lost
a tooth
and we were laughing he came in last
night lost a tooth we were laughing like
most kids lose that tooth when they're
eight and he was laughing we're carrying
on
and I
pulled my shirt up over my head so you
couldn't see my face and I grabbed a
quarter out of like my coin jar
I flat my wings in there
and I turned the lights on he was half
asleep he's like what are you doing
and I was like it's the tooth fairy and
inflation's bad
and I flicked a quarter on his bed and
he started dying laughing
and that he's left I just left
and that's the kind of story he's going
to tell at his deathbed that my dad was
funny and my dad was silly and my dad
made jokes
not that my dad told me a great life
lesson after the soccer game now he's
not gonna remember any of that crap he's
gonna remember I was annoying after
sporting events
but I really have been focusing lately
on being likable
and
um that doesn't mean a a doormat that
just means
that I'm I am enjoyable to be around and
I'm finding that that's making me an
infinitely more effective parent and
really co-worker and human being but
that's a whole other conversation
I want to add into that though so the
book I was telling you about
um is about the raising boys and I find
this is for both my teens
when you want to connect with your teen
you have to go where they are that my
son is not going to go shopping with me
and he's not going to sit down and watch
a Great British Bake Off he might but
not willingly I have to do what he wants
to do right and so last night for the
last few nights he's watching this
Formula One series on Netflix I heard
it's fantastic actually it's really good
yeah but I'm watching the Formula One
series and uh over you know not long ago
we watched violent night the the oh God
it was actually great David Harbor it's
a Christmas but it's super violent
violent night yeah it's great you should
put that in your parent of the Year
application I did it's but you know I've
gotta watch what he wants to watch or
my husband they go do things that my son
wants to do because he's not going to do
what we want to do and be like this is
great thanks for you know making me
watch Pride and Prejudice Mom that's not
going to work
but if I can do what he wants to do it
gains trust and I'm not making fun of it
yes you're you're participating I think
I I I like that especially around
entertainment things
and enjoyment things I also think it's
important
for my kid to come with me when we're
going to help somebody's house and do
servicey things right and so like that's
more entertainment type things yeah I
think that's right if you're always like
no kids we're watching this because my
house my TV well you're an idiot and
you're not likable nobody wants to be
around that guy right and you're not
that guy with your friends all right and
if you are you don't have any friends
because you're an ass like nobody wants
to be around you and it's important that
I know what makes my kid laugh yes and
that I know what my kids into first of
all yes because then I'm also I know who
his friends are and
um you know my husband every once in a
while will grab a remote and play video
games with him when he's playing online
so we're hearing the people he's talking
to but then we know about his life and
it's the same with my daughter it's
different a little bit because of her
special needs but if I want to do what
she is into or I can sit and make her
watch
you know stranger things we're just
gonna terrify her right so I I've seen a
profound transition in my my daughter
when I just walk into her room quietly
and I don't flick the lights on and off
and start throwing her stuffed animals
around like let's let's fight again if I
just go lay on the floor and just grab
my own coloring book and get right next
to her in color and we won't say
anything for five or ten minutes
and eventually she'll say
hey today is school and she'll just
launch in right and that's right what
you're saying but and that goes back to
me just being likable and it's just
getting in their world man yeah my
daughter loves to do jigsaw puzzles and
so this weekend I just put one out and
she just came over and we don't get a
lot of peaceful enjoyment time with her
because that's just not her world but
for an hour hour and a half we just sat
and did this puzzle together because I
know that that's something she'll she'll
want to join in and I can kind of you
know it's it's something that she enjoys
so I will come do that I love it yeah so
it's just being in their world because
then you get to know who they are I love
it it's great all right last question
let's do it piece of advice that you
love to give but find the hardest to
follow
eating nutritious stuff and sleep those
are the two that man I struggle big time
um and I found my sleep getting
increasingly worse I'm gonna have to
spend some Direct Time on it um I've met
with my doctor on it a couple months ago
and he gave me some pretty harsh advice
that I haven't put into practice yet
um
but he basically told me you gotta
change your life or you're not gonna be
with us much longer so I'm gonna have to
do that eventually but yeah please do I
need a job
there's some other idiot that will be
glad to spell their opinions Kelly
um but I so sleep and diet I just eat so
much junk food
um
uh the other one is
parenting
um showing up
uh
I often say kids they don't have
permission to hurt my feelings and when
I find when I'm tired or when I'm having
a season of self-doubt or I'm just not
feeling good about myself
man my daughter can flat out
crush me
um my son can crush me my wife can say
something that crushes me and
it's easy to sit here and say you just
gotta keep showing up just gotta keep
showing up man sometimes I just want to
go get a tent and sleep in the backyard
for a few nights and so I think that's
the other hard one is just to keep
showing up I do a better job of showing
up
than I do not eating gummy candies but
we'll see
what about you
uh I feel like I'm constantly telling my
kids especially probably other people
that you know
God's gonna handle this he's going to
take it and then boy I like to control
things like you know right now we're
dealing with the house stuff and I am
trying to control every little piece of
that
and my husband keeps you know spitting
my words back at me but I'm a control
freak and I tell me more Kelly
and I love control but boy I can tell
other people how you know
you just need to let that go and give
that to God and then I'm over here hold
on you're like I am God
I am